as upsetting as the ending to Avengers
infinity war was there's a good chance
that a lot of the most devastating
losses of the film would be reversed
when the fourth Avengers movie comes
along if you haven't seen infinity war
yet avert your eyes now considering the
fact that the sequels for Black Panther
guardians of the galaxy and spider-man
homecoming have all been confirmed the
very future of the MCU depends on a lot
of infinity war being undone
what we don't know yet is how the Russo
brothers will make that happen they
could do the obvious and draw directly
from the source material but there are
also other clues in Infinity Ward that
their plan might go in another direction
we won't know until May of 2019 exactly
how they do it but here are a few of the
ways infinity wars ending could be
reversed daughter of mine the most
obvious answer to how infinity war is
ending could be reversed is to follow
the comics and leave it all up to nebula
infinity war is partly based on the 1991
comic book miniseries Infinity Gauntlet
in which Thanos collects the six
Infinity stones and erases half the life
in the universe with his infamous snap
in the comics however that all takes
place in the beginning of the story near
the end though nebula uses Thanos his
momentary distraction to take the
gauntlet from him and one of her first
actions is to undo that OSes actions so
all the people phantos got rid of with
his genocidal snap and everyone who
didn't survive trying to take the
gauntlet from him are suddenly revived
conveniently nebula has survived the
battle in infinity war so that option is
still certainly on the table at the same
time though that might seem a little too
obvious and approach for the Russos who
clearly made a point of diverging from
the source material in other ways for
infinity war so let's consider some
other options as well
they've got soul there are a lot of
theorists who believe we're going to see
a pretty serious soul trade go down an
infinity war in the comics the soul
stone contains an entire world full of
lost spirits so some fans suspect the
victims of infinity wars conclusion
didn't really perish but were instead
absorbed into the soul stone that could
include Gamora
given her proximity to the stone at the
moment of her demise it's probably no
coincidence that
of infinity Wars survivors our core
members of The Avengers whose actor
counterparts plan to make this their
final Marvel movie justice Thanos had to
pay the price of gomorrah's life to get
the stone if the stone contains the
souls of Thanos as victims then it may
mean some horrible price will have to be
paid to free those victims and who
better to do that than the team that
first assembled to save the universe in
the first place
vision of the future seconds before
Corvus glaive breaks through the lab in
Wakanda Shuri stops her work on vision
to very quickly type something into the
display before throwing her gloves on
and attacking Corvis and since she
didn't separate vision from the mine
stone one has to assume that whatever
she was doing it wasn't finishing that
job one idea is that Sheree was actually
backing up visions consciousness just in
case the inevitable happened if he's not
trapped in the soul stone with the rest
due to the fact that he might not have a
soul in the traditional sense well he
may still be with us in another former
fashion if that's the case then the
Avengers might have an ace up their
sleeve they don't know about by
preserving visions digital consciousness
the team may learn some secrets about
the stones that even Thanos doesn't know
after all vision did mention feeling
like the stone was talking to him so
perhaps after being freed from its
intensity his backed up mind will be
clearer and able to give the Avengers
the information they need to reverse the
gnosis work he or she comes Captain
Marvel is coming and she may be the key
to everything the Carol Danvers of the
MCU will be different from the comics
version of the character Marvel boss
Kevin Feige has said Captain Marvel is
easily the strongest of all B MCU heroes
whereas in the comics tons of heroes
would technically beat her in that
department we also know josh brolin has
confirmed he's filmed scenes with brie
Larson for Avengers 4 so if the
post-credits scene wasn't enough of a
confirmation we know for sure that
she'll be in the movie and fighting
Thanos when Nick Fury saw what was
happening Captain Marvel wasn't one of
his calls it was his only call which
suggests that Fury knew she was the one
for the job we won't know the full
extent of her abilities until Avengers 4
or whether they have anything to do with
the reversal but how
thanos bites the dust' she'll be giving
him one of his biggest bites his own
worst enemy in the end the one who
reverses his victory may be Thanos
itself it's often been commented in the
comics that Thanos is the cause of his
many defeats time and time again the mad
Titan has grasped limitless power that
should have allowed him to brush aside
all challengers but still he failed but
saying danos is his own worst enemy may
prove to be more than cliche or metaphor
right before he sacrifices Gamora he
tells her that he ignored his destiny
once and that he can't do it again of
course we didn't get to see whatever
missed moment he was talking about
before but perhaps his daughter nebula
did time travel is expected to play a
big role in Avengers 4 so if there was a
time when Thanos ignored his insane
crusade to slaughter half the universe
perhaps nebula can lead everyone to it
and figure out how to recruit that
version of him to join the war against
himself crazier things have happened
dream a little dream it might seem cheap
at first but the idea that everything in
the infinity war was some kind of sick
dream isn't completely unsupported think
back when vanos acquired the soul stone
after Thanos throws Gamora from the edge
of the cliff as the ultimate sacrifice
of someone he loves a bright light
issues from the sky above that us and
envelops everything then Thanos blacks
out and awakens somewhere else with the
sole stone in hand perhaps that exact
moment is when his plan has gone awry
but what if Gamora was right and Thanos
didn't actually love anything enough to
earn the stone
if so Danis waking up in a different
place may have indicated that he failed
the test and was instead in the interior
of the soul stone dreaming out his
supposed fate as master of the universe
it's pretty unlikely but we'll have to
wait to find out for sure next year when
Avengers 4 hits theaters thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]